Let's go next to our caller from the three
one zero area code.
Who's calling today from three one zero.
Well, that would be me, David.
And who is this Mark?
Victor, go ahead.
Um, I was wondering, uh, your thoughts on
this Ukrainian situation and multiplied by
how many different countries do you potentially
think, you know, Trump could be meddling in
how many countries is Trump meddling in?
I have no idea.
I mean, I think it's probably more than two.
Uh, but I, I really, I couldn't say for sure.
Okay.
Well thank you very much.
All right, very good.
Thank you for the call.
I know that was, uh, I hope that that was
informative.
Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five one area code caller from nine five one.
Who is this?
Where are you calling from?
Did David on me?
Yes it is.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Okay.
Um, hi, my name is Corrine.
Um, I'm a black college student.
I go to Cal state Los Angeles and currently
in Los Angeles right now.
Um, I'm actually a big fan of your show, kind
of becoming a member very soon.
So, um, look after me.
Anyways.
Um, my question is I would really like your
insights or maybe your speculation on kind
of this hypothetical political situation I've
been thinking about.
Is that okay?
Okay.
So let's just say Bernie or Warren become
the 2020 presidential or they win the 2020
presidential election and they become like
gay, one of the most progressive presidents
of countries seen in the modern era, assuming
that their policies that they're pursuing,
assuming that they will pursue the policies
that they campaign on, what is the likelihood
of them actually enacting these progressive
policies with a, let's say, democratically
controlled house and Senate, even though most
it, most of the Democrats in the Senate and
the house are lean more corporate.
Yeah.
So Kerryn you're, you're asking a really good
question and it's so important to understand
this no president, no matter how much we like
or dislike their policy agenda accomplishes
any significant of what they say they are
going to do.
Trump is an acute example.
I mean, he's done almost nothing, right?
Uh, he, he hasn't fixed trade.
He hasn't built the wall.
He hasn't done healthcare.
He's done like nothing but even presidents
where we like their ideas like Bernie or Warren
in a, in a really optimistic scenario where
they have both the house and Senate maybe
for for two years of their presidency, maybe
for four years, you know, maybe for six.
It's very rare that you have a president who
is there for two terms that has the house
and Senate on their side for all eight years
of their term.
Even then you only get some things done partially
because even people in your own party don't
necessarily agree.
Like for example, the division in the democratic
party electorate, uh, in democratic party
elected officials about healthcare.
And because Republicans do have tools to obstruct
no matter what.
So I think it's really important that we all
just know.
And it sounds like you know, it Kerryn from
your question that the policy platform of
the person we select is a starting point and
hopefully they can do some things but no president
gets it all done.
The more ambitious, the less likely it is
to get done.
This is a reality.
This is how the system is developed with checks.
And balances and having to get through a lot
to really make big change.
And we just have to recognize that.
We have to understand that when we evaluate
the success of a presidency, Korean listening,
I don't know if you're using a building blocks
or something like that, but it's very loud.
It's cause it's raining out.
Oh, it's raining.
Okay.
Gotcha.
So yeah, listen, you're, you're thinking about
all the right stuff, Karen.
All right.
Um, if I can just ask you one more follow
up really quick if that's okay.
Um, so save born Bernie or Warren get their,
um, get their agenda through Congress, right.
What is the likelihood of that if there are
laws going unchallenged by like a right-wing
group and then being struck down, but one
of Trump's appointees
that it's so hard to say because it depends
on the type of thing that you're talking about.
If something gets through Congress, it is
a much more difficult path to getting it struck
down like bike by a court.
We saw that with Obamacare, um, in, in many
ways, although there were some success.
It really just depends, you know, things done
by executive order can pretty, pretty often
be undone by the next executive orders.
So that's different, but it's too, it's too
general a question to be able to answer it
with any specificity.
Karin, thank you for the call.
I appreciate it and I hope to hear from you
again.
If you're holding it,
don't hang up because I'm taking a very quick
break and then going right back to the front,